moi
I think a lot of people look at hula as
just women dancing but um we love it man
hula is a story to tell the story the
way the ancient hawaiians did you really
need to put yourself in that dance you
need to live like them you need to chant
like them
you need to train like them basically
you need to become them
mo na Ivanova will be hollow is the hula
school we perform all over the world in
ancient times Warriors are actually
recruited from the hollow the chief
would come to look from the ranks of the
advanced male dancers warriors were
selected the philosophy of our law is to
kind of replicate that for male hula
were basically telling warrior stories
and to dance like a warrior
you need a train like a warrior
[Music]
we train in a private piece of land on
the west side of Oahu using only what
ancient hawaiians had
whether it's rocks the sand the ocean
when we come to practice we expect to
die
it's strenuous on the legs but it's also
to train your mind I tell myself and the
rest of the boys if I fall it's because
my body just gave up
[Music]
one of the hardest workouts we do would
be climbing the coconut tree
sometimes you reach the top and your
legs are shaking because you know you're
holding your weight and to look down
knowing that nothing's holding you you
got to kind of have this warrior mindset
as like you know that this is what I
want you know I'm gonna get this you
know when these gentlemen come to hula
they're like a ball of clay that's cool
more I look at it as my responsibility
to shape them into better individuals
that are fathers better sons that are
brothers our goal is that when these men
are done dancing that they leave here
better people
[Music]
what who let us for me culturally it
still takes me back to Tejada ye used to
be
people sometimes are losing that Aloha
for each other that love for each other
and hula just gives you that reality
check man
I'm dancing until my kneecaps fall off
and even after that I'm gonna do
whatever I can for the hollow
you know we have this Brotherhood where
we take care of each other we help push
each other it's my passion and I look
forward to seeing where hula takes me in
life
you
[Music]